puis la justice robert badinter qui a
apporté de nombreux éclairages sur ses
intentions du 6 nouvelles plus libre
plus humaine plus efficace justice libre
justice humaine ou plutôt humanisé ce
sont les deux maîtres mots de la
philosophie du nouveau garde des sceaux
tel qu'il a présenté ce matin justice
libre affirmations de l'indépendance
totale des magistrats réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature dont les
pouvoirs seront étendus et dont tous les
membres seront élus concertation avec
les organisations syndicales et
professionnelles de magistrats est aussi
d'avocats d'ailleurs sur tous les textes
proposés liberté indépendance de la
justice le garde des sceaux a voulu
donner l'exemple
l'abolition de la peine de mort sera
proposé le premier jour de la session
d'automne au parlement d'ici là les
avocats généraux ne recevront aucune
consigne pour ou contre de robert
badinter non faiblement est une question
qui engage la conscience de chacun
d'abord la conscience des magistrats
dans une affaire où elle peut se poser
par conséquent je ne donnerai jamais et
sur ce point d orgue d instruction d
indication de quelque nature que ce soit
aux avocats généraux chacun se
déterminera selon sa conscience getis
humaniser deuxième volet développement
des garanties d'indemnisation des
victimes
élargissement et augmentation de l'aide
judiciaire enfin retour à la politique
de libération conditionnelle des petits
délinquants
c'est un renversement total de la
politique suivie depuis quelques années
il y a beaucoup de travail
il faudra tout de même un peu d'argent
le milieu de la santé jacques rallier à
lui